Alex, since you've been spending quite some time in Korea,...
...do you know who this group is?
They are a group of singers, in fact,...
...there are 13 members and they are also one of my favorites.
Are you kidding me?
That's Super Junior!
In Korea people call them "idol star", right?
Well, when they refer to "idol", I guess they mean child stars.
Well, I don't know about kids or teenagers becoming a celebrity at such a young age.
If I had a child, and he or she wanted to jump into that field, I would dissuade him or her.
I swear to God, there would be more things that a kid would lose than gain.
Children at their age, they need to play with their friends and family, at school or wherever,...
...and sometimes study as hard as they can.
You know, have a normal life.
I think that being so different from others, especially at such a young age doesn't seem so good.
I have to partially agree with you there;...
...becoming a star, or celebrity at a young age could leave a person with a lonely life,...
...but not necessarily.
He or she could enjoy their lives to the fullest doing what they enjoy and what they are also good at!
That being said, there are some role models who started their careers at young ages and went on to be successful.